ronaldinho madame monsieur bonsoir très
heureux de vous avoir avec nous ce soir
vous avez 21 ans vous êtes une super
star du foot au brésil 14 sélections
dans l'équipe du brésil
bientôt superstar en europe puisque vous
allez signer avec psg pour pour cinq ans
on dit vous êtes plus fort que ronaldo
c'est vrai non non je j'ai commencé
depuis peu
ronaldo c'est un joueur confirmé et que
j'ai depuis longtemps vous appelez et
ronaldinho parce que vous n'êtes pas si
petit que ça finalement vous faites un
mètre soixante dix huit 71 kg petit
ronaldo ronaldinho est ce que tu ai dit
non
alors changé depuis
optique dans vos petites dents en avant
là c'est très joli tout les brésiliennes
sont folles de vous à cause de ces deux
petites dents qui me dépasse un peu là
bon c'est calme il ya des pauses yankees
mais monsieur chercher calme alors votre
vrai nom c ronaldo des assisses moreira
on vous appelle ronaldo gaucho parce que
vous venez de porto allègre qui est la
région où il ya des gauchos qui s'occupe
du bétail dans la campagne vous êtes né
dans une favela une famille passionnée
de football votre père était soudeur
dans un arsenal mais en plus il
s'occupait des voitures sur le parking
du club de foot gremio à porto allègre
et votre frère votre frère c'est roberto
assis ce qui est un grand joueur
effectivement roberto tellement grands
joueurs que pour le garder le club de
porto allègre le gremio avait offert une
villa avec une piscine au père de
ronaldo et de roberto et votre père est
mort quand vous aviez huit ans
d'hydrocution il est tombé dans la
piscine il est mort d'hydrocution
exactement comment ça s'est terminé
moi j'étais jeune à l'époque mais elle
est décédée dans une piscine mais je ne
suis pas dans quelles circonstances vous
avez huit ans est votre premier cadeau
ça a été un ballon et des chaussures de
foot et vous avez appuyé à dribbler
contre les meubles du salon
c'est exact oui je jouais beaucoup de
j'étais jeune je jouais avec mon chien
alors vous êtes devenu célèbre en
quelques secondes en 1999 dans un match
qui opposait le brésil au venezuela
votre premier match dans la seleçao vous
entrez en deuxième mi-temps et raconter
ce qui s'est passé comment vous êtes
devenu une star en un match
c'est pas mal je n'ai pas encore quand
même apprécié les gens me connaissaient
même os brisés
le président m'a connu
même le monde
bon mon jeu dans ce match alors traite
ou dont vous êtes devenu une star en
2000 j'avais 20 ans et le club anglais
de leeds vous offre 500 millions la même
année milan ac vous propose 48 millions
de francs par an et le gremio fait une
contre-proposition 1 900 mille francs
par mois est ce que quand on a 20 ans
quel effet ça fait de devoir qu'on veut
ce prix-là kadhafi sauf à la
dure d'aborder ces questions d'argent
moi je
ne pense pas à l'argent je pense
simplement été ma famille et toutes mes
pensées se tournent
vers le jeu je ne pense pas à l'argent
parce que l'argent c'est quelque chose
de compliqué surtout chez toi à l'argent
je n'ai pas bien joué donc c'est un jeu
qui m'intéresse alors vous refuser
toutes ses propositions parce que
finalement vous êtes séduits par l'idée
de venir jouer à paris et donc le 12
janvier 2001 une radio sport fm annonce
votre signature de contrats le psg
dément et le parisien à ce moment là
fait sa une avec marc est le sauveur
puisque évidemment comme vous le savez
on a besoin de joueurs de foot au ps
chez les mecs on a besoin de mecs qui
bouge pendant le jingle
alors il ya eu quand même des réactions
assez négative au brésil à l'idée de
vous perdre à la légende porto allègre
sont très tristes à l'idée que vous
partiez
jeune je jouais longtemps au gremio
temps dans mon club et ses gants
donc j'ai fait un climat de confiance
avec eux c'était ma famille et donc
quand j'ai parti j'ai été triste mais
maintenant j'ai un nouveau nouvelles à
venir une nouvelle vie oui ils ont quand
même mis sur la pelouse du stade à porto
allègre et ils ont quand même mis des
sacs avec des faux billets à l'intérieur
avec marquez psg dessus c'est pas très
sympa quand
il est parti puis c'est le traducteur il
va revenir
[Applaudissements]
je m'attendais à cela mais je vais
prendre une décision et j'ai pris la
bonne décision
je veux évoluer en tant que joueur et en
tant que personne et paris c'est le bon
endroit afin que je me développe
harmonieusement débat du personnel il ya
un truc un peu étrange quand même
ronaldinho c'est que vous avez choisi de
venir au psg à cause de la bonne
réputation du psg au brésil
une réputation officiers même dans le
monde entier mais tout ça c'est un grand
club
une bonne saison mais tout le monde sait
que c'est un truc
que peu évolué positivement dans la
brèche une période où il ya eu beaucoup
de brésiliens qui ont joué au psg et
ricardo il ya eu valdo et leonardo rails
vous êtes le 12e brésilien a porté les
couleurs de la capitale alors le contrat
est toujours pas signé pour le moment
non encore je n'ai pas signé de contrat
je vais venir certainement joue ici
monsieur des problèmes toujours avec le
club de porto avec qui veut pas vous
laisser partir gratuitement
il ya une négociation entre le psg et
lorsqu'ils auront trouvé un accord bon
la situation sera résolue mon niveau
vous connaissez paris non c'est la
première fois que vous venez à paris
mardi soir avant je connaissais rien
pour connaître cette ville je recherche
un nouveau domicile et connaissent rien
qui rit ouais tout ça on va vous sortir
on va vous donner un endroit super tour
eiffel
c'est pourtant à gramat réjouit bien sûr
c'est un surdoué capable de jouer au
football après mais c'est pas grave en
même temps mise à part le fait qu'on
vous a collé trois rôles à la coupe du
monde
non nous avons mise à part la victoire
de la france sur le brésil en coupe du
monde pour grand chose vous savez quoi
du foot français on à l'union
je connais quasiment jeu
français
beaucoup doit penser que je trouve très
fort ici daniel
qu'un
joueur en france s'est félicité
bon je chanterai pas dit si oui pourquoi
l'équipe de france est devenue la
meilleure équipe du monde à votre avis
devant le brésil
mais on
gagne ils ont eu beaucoup de chance
ils ont mérité cette victoire
les brésiliens je conçois
mais j'espère que la prochaine fin nous
vaincrons en janvier de cette année 2001
vous ai fait un match à six contre six
dans un jardin de bono crs avec maradona
vous adorez maradona vous l'avais
tellement dévorer des yeux pendant le
match que tu es un match amical bien
entendu que vous avez perdu et à la fin
il a dit maradona a dit en parlant de
ronaldinho je voulais une fois dans ma
vie jouer contre toi car tu es le
dernier qui me fait rêver dans le
football a beaucoup
cela m'a beaucoup touché
c'était un moment très spécial que je
n'oublierai jamais non non j'ai quand
ils disent elles étaient défoncés aussi
donc les pendules à l'heure
alors au brésil vous avez jamais
afficher votre argent vous ne vous
reliez dans une fiat tipo au brésil est
ce que à paris avec un salaire important
si vous allez avoir quand même 1 5
million de francs par mois + 10 millions
de formes prime de signature est-ce que
vous avez gardé votre fiat tipo
oui mais ici il va falloir trouver une
voiture une bonne voiture dans laquelle
je puisse me déplacer bien est-ce que
vous avez choisi paris parce que vous
êtes toujours célibataire
oui ici à coups de jolies femmes
magnifiques
tant que célibataire dont je suis prêt à
faire des rencontres et peut-être je me
marierai qu'une française a alors vous
voulez lancer un appel vous disions en
référé
moi
ça me tue au brésil juste d'arriver ici
en france pour l'instant je suis heureux
on est seul mais bon je suis prêt à
faire des rencontres mais profitez de
votre tranquilité un petit peu absent
pognon chair d'os
la première invitée ce soir
les corrections de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux